hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
we're going to be going over
diabetes mellitus specifically the
nursing
management what i'm going to do is i'm
going to focus specifically on the
things you need to know for the nclex
exam
and your nursing lecture exam and after
this video be sure to go to my website
registerednessrn.com and take the free
quiz
that will test your knowledge on this
material a card should be popping up so
you can access this
now this video is part of a series about
an nclex review over the diabetic
patient
in the previous video we went over the
pathophysiology the causes the
complications the different types
the nursing assessment and things like
that so if you haven't watched that
video be sure to watch that video after
you watch
this okay so let's get started first
let's begin by talking about the nurse's
role when you're taking care of the
diabetic patient your role as a nurse is
to educate
to administer medications to assess and
monitor
them and the best way to help you learn
this
and help your patient learn this is to
follow the triangle of diabetes
management it's a little triangle it's
continuous because
everything works together you have diet
on one side meds on the other exercise
and in the middle you have
monitor because based on their diet how
they're exercising will determine what
type of medications they need
especially when that type 2 diabetic
because a lot of times they don't even
need medications if they can manage
their diet and exercise
and then all through that you're going
to monitor exercise
they're going to make sure that their
glucose is good before they exercise if
not they're going to eat a little snack
and they're going to monitor their
glucose
so all that goes together now for nclex
what do you need to know
specifically because this is what this
lecture is all about getting you to know
what you need to know for nclex
okay as a nurse you need to know diet
how you're going to educate the patient
based on what they can eat what
food specifically really making sure you
know what foods they can have
exercise what type of exercise they
should do
how they're going to monitor their
glucose taking their
insulin therapy things like that drugs
specifically really the drugs
pharmacological aspect you need to know
all about insulin the complications of
insulin the different types of insulin
like you're rapid you're short your
intermediate long and those peak times
and a little bit later in the lecture
i'm going to give you a mnemonic on how
to remember that because it's a little
complicated to remember
hopefully the mnemonic will help you and
the drugs that cause
hypo and hyperglycemia and different
types of oral medications that your type
2 diabetics
will take so first let's start about the
diet
now diets in diabetic patients are very
individualistic it depends on how much
how physical
physically active they are how they eat
things like that so there's not a
one-size-fits-all diet they have to do
some tweaking
generally it's a good guideline to
follow the ada diet which is the
american diabetic association diet
and here's what it says what you want to
concentrate on is the foods that are in
each category and how much they can have
of each um percentage of each category
so carbs a diabetic needs to consume at
least 45
carbs in their diet throughout the day
so this includes like grains those
starchy vegetables like potatoes and
corn those sweets have hidden carbs in
them
like cookies and soda and dried beans
and milk
next are fats this is the one you want
to limit the most
no more than about 20 percent
and they want to limit those saturated
trans fats and cholesterol and those are
found in foods such as
lard gravies whole milk fatty meats like
bologna sausage hot dogs
and encouraged as an alternative those
healthy fats like the mono saturated and
the polysaturated
which are like avocados olives and nuts
so teaching them how to pick healthy
fats compared to unhealthy fats
and then proteins um they want at least
15 percent to 20 percent
of proteins in their diet and also let
them know that meats do not
increase the glycemic index so that is
good
and meat they need to eat really try to
avoid those red meats they aren't as
healthy so you want to concentrate on
chicken turkey fish plant-based beans
egg whites and low-fat cheese
now let's go over the exercise part
okay the best type of exercise for a
diabetic to do
is the aerobic type exercise because
this helps the body use insulin so what
type of exercise is best
great test questions come from this
they'll give you an exercise regimen
which one's the best for the diabetic
this includes like those cardio
exercises
that require you to run and really get
the heart pumping
like walking running and swimming okay
education pieces that you need to give
the diabetic
prior to exercising because remember
they have issues with
managing their glucose and their insulin
so
prior to exercising they want to check
their blood sugar and if their blood
sugar is less than 100
it's a good idea to eat a snack because
if you're already starting out
on the lower end and you're going to
exercise because when you exercise you
use glucose
you're going to bottom out and
experience hypoglycemia
so tell them to carry some simple carbs
with them
um remember in the previous video we
went in depth about simple carbs and
those
this is like hard candy fruit juice
honey
in case they do get that hypoglycemic
attack they can just pop that in the
mouth
and help increase the blood sugar signs
of hypoglycemia
is they can be sweaty clammy
confused lightheaded double vision
tremors
remember the phrase i'm sweaty cold and
clammy
please give me some candy so that can
help
you and your patient remember what to do
for hypoglycemia
now they plan on exercising for a long
period of time it's a good idea to check
their blood sugar prior to exercise
during and
after just to monitor it because you're
going to be using a lot of glucose
in the body now if they prior to
exercising if the glucose is high
instead of
low usually greater than 250 and there's
urine
and there's ketones present in their
urine they need to avoid
exercising because the body
is already burning ketones in the system
it can't get to the glucose
so they don't want to exercise and burn
even more ketones cause some acid-base
imbalances
which they can go into dka and it would
not be good so they need to hold off
now what are some signs of high blood
sugar remember
the three p's polyuria polyphasia and
polydipsia polyuria is where you have
frequent urination
polyphagia is where you're extremely
hungry and polydipsia is where you have
a frequent thirst and just remember the
same
i'm hot and dry i must be on a sugar
high because those symptoms
are present in hyperglycemia okay
now let's get to the meat and potatoes
of the lecture
then we're going to go over medications
a lot of test questions come from here
what we're going to cover we're going to
cover our oral medications
the medications that cause hyper and
hypoglycemia and
insulin okay but first let's talk about
oral medications oral medications are
typically
for your type 2 diabetics and they are
usually started when the type 2 diabetic
can't manage their blood sugar with
either diet and exercise diet exercise
is the first
things we want and then they will be put
on medications as a last resort
so let's talk about those first one are
your
sulfonyureas this is
um the most common types and these drugs
include glyburide
glipizide diabetes amarillo and these
drugs
typically and help you remember in eyes
like zy
z-i-d-s my m-i-d-e-s or the rides
r-i-d-e-s and what these drugs do is
they
stimulate the beta cells because
remember your beta cells secrete insulin
to make insulin but one thing you've got
to watch out for this drug will cause
hypoglycemia
and absolutely no alcohol the patient
should never ingest
alcohol drinks or anything like that
that contains alcohol because you can
experience
extreme hypoglycemia because alcohol
already causes
low blood sugar levels so does this
medication you put those two together
and you have a bad case scenario so
remember that with this
drug no alcohol next drug category
are the drugs known as the myglitonides
and this is drugs that usually
end in the g-l-i-n-i-d-e
like repentaglinide and these stimulate
the beta cells
to produce insulin source similar as
your sulfa niurias
and these are usually taken with the
first bite of food so an education piece
whenever a patient's on these type of
drugs
you want but right before they eat their
food they need to take this medication
okay next is the baguanides and this
is a very popular drug as a nurse i see
this drug all the time
uh metformin that's a common drug of
this category
also called glucophage and what this
drug does is it decreases the liver
stores
of glucose and
an education piece you want to watch out
for this and even as a nurse working
on the floor this is usually held about
48 hours
prior to surgery or before a heart cath
especially with a heart cath because
those dyes that they're giving
during the heart cath and metformin and
those dyes do not go together and they
can cause
renal failure so you want to watch renal
function and this drug can also cause
diarrhea next is the alpha
glucoside inhibitors this is the drugs
known as precose or glycemic
and this lowers the blood glucose by
breaking down starchy foods in the gut
so education piece with this is that you
want to take this medication with the
first bite of food since it works on the
food you are taking in
the next drug category is a mouthful
it's called the
thiazonelidineons and these are also
called for short as tzds and these drugs
a common one is glytozone and it
decreases the glucose production in the
liver
also um brand names actos and avandia
with this drug however you have to watch
the liver function and the heart
function because
um studies have shown that there may be
an increased risk of mis in patients who
take these drugs
now let's look at the drugs that can
cause hypoglycemia and hyperglycemia
okay your beta blockers those um like
metoprol
atenolol things that end in olol
they can actually mask the symptoms of
hypoglycemia and they can cause it
alcohol can as well aspirin those
sulfonylureas that we talked about with
the oral
diabetic medications you don't want them
to take alcohol as well with those type
of medications
your moa inhibitors these are the drugs
used to treat depression
and bactrim which is a popular
antibiotic so if your patients on that
you want to watch out for that
and some drugs that can cause elevated
blood sugars
are the thiazides that like hctz those
are diuretics
glucocorticoids like hydrocortisone
prednisone
and estrogen therapy and watch out for
your oral contraceptives as well
now let's hit on insulin okay
with this what we're going to do is
we're going to talk about some key
points you need to remember with insulin
and then we're going to go over a couple
mnemonics on how to remember
what drugs of insulin are either rapid
short intermediate or long and then give
you some mnemonics on how to remember
that onset peak and duration
time so first let's go over the little
side notes you need to know about giving
insulin
okay whenever you're given insulin it's
usually a sub-q
injection the only insulin you can give
iv
is regular insulin remember that it's
only one that can go intravenous
but whenever you give it you give it
sub-q and it goes into
the fat subcues fat of the skin and you
want to rotate
sides you never want to use the same
side rule of thumb
rotate sides out where you're not using
one site more than
one time within a two to three week
period because they can develop
lipodustry dystrophia which is
pitting of like fat and they'll get
dimples in their skin and it'll mess up
their fat layer
never after you give insulin subcu
don't massage the area or put heat at it
because this will increase
absorption faster than what the body can
handle and you are going to have
increased chances of having a
hypoglycemic attack so don't do that
and whenever you're mixing insulins
remember the little
phrase clear to cloudy clear represents
regular
insulin and nph represents cloudy and
how you remember that
is the initials are in for registered
nurse
r represents regular n represents nph
so clear to cloudy whenever you're
mixing those now some things that can
happen
with diabetics who take insulin
these couple phenomenons these
phenomenons people get
confused one's a phenomenon one's an
effect and they both
deal with high blood glucose levels but
they happen
during different times in the night okay
so let's talk about the dawn phenomenon
let the word help you
okay dawn the crack of dawn in the
morning this happens during the waking
hours the patient's going to have
hyperglycemia during the waking hours
and this is because the body
in preparation of waking up the body
shoots
you some extra glucose because it knows
you're going to need it for those waking
hours and this typically happens between
five to eight am and but the diabetic
can't
handle that extra glucose because they
are they have issues with insulin
remember insulin helps take glucose into
the cell
so in the morning they're going to have
really high glucose levels to help
combat that
just throwing on maybe a nighttime dose
of
nph was it which is an intermediate
acting insulin
can help counteract that hyperglycemia
whenever they're waking at the crack of
dawn
in the mid in those waking hours next is
the somji effect
i like to remember this psalm g starts
with s for the sleeping hours this
happens whenever they're
asleep typically the hours between 2
a.m to 3 a.m and what's happening
is that they're having a drop in blood
sugar around these hours
and the body says hey we've got to fix
this so they release the hormones like
cortisol your catecholamines
and growth hormone to increase that
blood sugar but the diabetic can't cope
with all that extra glucose because they
have insulin
issues so they're so what happens is
that they get hyperglycemia but to help
counteract that
you want to prevent those glucose levels
from falling
between that two to three hour so eating
a bedtime
snack can help that or maybe decreasing
that bedtime
insulin dose okay so now let's go over
the different types of insulins okay you
have
rapid short intermediate and long
i like to remember it as ready set
inject love because we're injecting
into the diabetic and rapid um
ready uh short set intermediate inject
and
l love so i like to remember that now
how i like to do this you can just get a
piece of paper whenever
you're fixing to take your test write
out the word insulin and
from top to bottom we're going to start
at rapid and go to long
and we're going to make this correlate
with what
insulin types are in each category
okay so we have rapid remember
ready so rapid we're going to use the i
and
insulin so r a p
d next we have short
acting for set ready set so the s
we have intermediate inject i
and we're going to use the u
intermediate means middle
so the u and the word insulin is in the
middle so that's going to represent
our in our intermediate drugs and
and one type of intermediate insulin
acting drug
is humalin in so we're going to put
humulin
in and i'm just going to put a line to
help separate that and separate that
from that
and then l for long that's our last
one's long acting
so we're going to write l for long okay
so now you have your categories you have
rapid short
intermediate the u's in the middle so we
know it's intermediate and long
so now let's just add the types of
insulins to help us remember
okay we're going to use the
a okay rapid are your logs
humalog and novelog so we have
humalog here
and then we have novel law novalog over
here
okay next we're going to go to short
water short acting ones
all your regular insulins so humulin
are novel and are ones that end in r
are your regular so we're going to
remember regular we're going to use the
r in short
just put reg for regular and then we're
going to go to our intermediate
these are our ones that end in n instead
of r so
humulin in your nphs
novel on in so we're going to use the n
and just put
n ph and then we're going to go to our
next drugs
which are the long acting and this is
the easiest ones even when remembering
peak and
onset and we know we have levomir
and then we have lantus
okay so that helps you remember what
drugs are what because on exams they
like to throw out
humalog and you have to know the peak so
just write that out before you take your
test and have that
and what helps you remember this is just
re-watching this part of the video and
writing it out over and over helps you
remember which drugs are which
now let's go over the mnemonics on how
to remember the specifically the peak
and duration and onset of these specific
drugs
okay now let's look at the different
categories of
insulins the rapid the short the
intermediate and the long and let's
look at the onset peak and duration and
specifically what you want to know for
exams
are the peak times because this is when
the patient
is most at risk for hypoglycemia
now with these mnemonics i wanted to
make them nursing related because
chances are if you're watching this
video you're going to be a nurse and
helping things
that are related to what you're doing
help you remember them and each of these
mnemonics
is going to tell you whether it's rapid
short interacting
or intermediate or long and each number
will correlate
in the same order with onset peak and
duration
so let's see what they say okay rapid
these remember are your logs your
humalog and novolog
and the onset of this the rapids are 15
minutes
the peak is one hour and the duration is
three hours
so how in the world are you going to
remember all this because in nursing we
have to get a little creative how we can
remember stuff
so remember this phrase 15 minutes
feels like an hour during three
rapid responses okay so clue whenever
you remember this
this deals with the rapid insulins 15
minutes
is the onset because it's the first
number you see
an hour is the peak and the duration
and the duration is three okay
next let's look at short short acting
insulins they're
on set are 30 minutes the peak is two
hours and the duration is eight hours
to help you remember all those numbers
remember the phrase
short staff nurses went from 30 patients
to eight patients so short you know this
is a short acting insulin
and 30 is the onset two
is the peak and the duration is
eight next intermediate acting the onset
is two hours the peak is eight hours and
the duration is
16 hours remember the phrase nurses play
hero 2 8 16
year olds nurses play hero these are
your mph
drugs like humulin in or nph so nurses
n p play and h hero and
two is your onset your peak is eight and
your duration is 16.
next long acting your onset this is the
easiest one to remember them all because
there's only two numbers you have to
remember
the onset is two hours there is no peak
with your long acting insulins
like level mir atlantis and the duration
is 24 hours so
a phrase to help you remember this is
the two
long nursing shifts never peaked but
lasted 24 hours
2 represents the onset long represents
its long acting
never peak because there's no peak with
long acting and lasting 24 hours
is your duration so that is the nursing
management
of diabetes now go take that quiz on my
website register nursery.com and test
your knowledge
and be sure to check out the other
videos in this series and thank you so
much for watching and please consider
subscribing to this youtube channel